The Truth About Prepositions and the End of
Sentences
A great man once said, “This is the sort
of English up with which I will not put.”
Eloquently highlighting the ridiculousness
of strictly adhering to the rule against ending
a sentence with a preposition, Winston Churchill
may not have realized that his defiance is
supported by history.
As it turns out, there was never any such
generally recognized rule.
So where did the idea that you shouldn’t
end a sentence with a preposition start?
Many writers in Restoration Era England (1660-1689),
and in particular “Glorious John” Dryden
(one of the greatest poets, dramatists and
literary critics of the 17th century), believed
they had vastly improved the quality of English
literature over their “Tudor and Elizabethan
ancestors:”
The language, wit, and conversation of our
age, are improved and refined above the last
. . . these absurdities, which those poets
[e.g. Shakespeare] committed [were due to]
the want of education and learning.
The additional education and learning that
Dryden claimed included a mastery of Latin,
a language he revered.
And, since in Latin one cannot end a sentence
with a preposition, Dryden contended that
it shouldn’t be allowed in English either.
(This is the exact same reasoning behind why,
for a very brief time, it was considered incorrect
in some circles to split an infinitive.)
Influential, many listened to him including
Bishop Robert Lowth, a fellow of the Royal
Society of London and author of A Short Introduction
to English Grammar (1762).
An extremely popular textbook on the subject,
the Short Introduction included what came
to be known as “Dryden’s rule,” although
even Lowth acknowledged that ending a sentence
with a preposition was not only dominant “in
common conversation [but also that it] suits
very well with the familiar style in writing.”
Nonetheless, since Lowth, like Dryden, felt
that “placing the preposition before the
relative is more graceful,” and since those
two literary giants were in favor of it, many
adopted the style.
By the dawn of the 20th century, it had taken
on the characteristics of a rule – particularly
among grammar school teachers.
However, literary scholars knew better (but
no one was listening to them).
As late as 1926, when Henry Fowler published
a Dictionary of Modern English Usage, he described
the “rule” as a “cherished superstition.”
As for today, according to the Oxford Dictionaries,
there are four primary types of sentences
where it sounds more natural to end a sentence
with a preposition:
Infinitive: Joe had no one to go with.
Who, what, where type questions: What song
were you listening to?
Passive: The cat was let in.
Relative clauses: That’s the man she lived
with.
The Oxford Dictionaries website also recommend
a joke to really drive the point home:
A snobbish English teacher was sitting in
an Atlanta airport coffee shop waiting for
her flight back to Connecticut when a friendly
Southern Belle sat down next to her.
“Where y’all goin’ to?” asked the
Southern Belle.
Turning her nose in the air, the snob replied,
“I don’t answer people who end their sentences
with prepositions.”
The Southern Belle thought a moment, and tried
again.
“Where y’all going’ to, BITCH?”